.
Vor Kurzem hab ich wieder angefangen
voll zu arbeiten nach der Babypause.
Da war unser Freundchen der Sonne
2,5 Monate alt.
Deshalb werde ich oft gefragt,
wie ich das hinkriege,
mit Familie und Beruf.
Na ja. Ich kriege es so hin,
wie viele Väter auch.
Indem ich
einen Partner zuhause habe.
Es ist ja heute
nichts Besonderes mehr,
wenn eine Frau Karriere macht.
Aber wenn ein Mann zuhause bleibt,
und sich um die Kinder kümmert,
wird er entweder kritisch beäugt,
Kann der das?
Die armen Kinder.
Oder wie ein Held gefeiert.
Was für ein Mann.
So oder so, mein Mann und ich
sind nicht die Norm.
Die basiert zum großen Teil
auf der Idee,
dass Mütter von Natur aus
die besseren Eltern sind.
Und dass sie eine
besondere Bindung zum Kind haben,
die Väter so nicht haben.
Im Jahr 2020 ist man
vielleicht geneigt zu sagen,
Alles Quatsch. Geschlechterrollen
sind gesellschaftliche Konstrukte,
Na ja, Geschlechterrollen
sind sicher
gesellschaftlich
und kulturell geprägt,
Das heißt ja nicht zwingend,
dass es nicht auch einen biologischen
Einfluss geben könnte.
Deshalb schauen
wir uns heute die Biologie
hinter Vätern und Müttern an.
Und beantworten die Frage:
Sind Väter die schlechteren Mütter?
Frauen und Männer sollen
gleichberechtigt sein, klar.
Aber das heißt nicht,
dass Frauen und Männer
gleich sein müssen.
Gerade in Sachen Nachwuchs
gibt es ja
offensichtliche
biologische Unterschiede
zwischen Frauen und Männern,
die sich auch auf die Beziehung
zum Kind auswirken könnten.
Hat diese besondere Bindung zum Kind,
die man Müttern nachsagt,
vielleicht eine
grundbiologische Basis?
Oder, wie ich lieber sage,
eine grundchemische?
Die Schwangerschaft
und die Zeit nach der Geburt
sind ein wahrer Hormontrip.
Ich will auf das wohl berühmteste
Schwangerschaftshormon eingehen
nämlich Oxytocin.
Oxytocin wird auch
das Kuschelhormon genannt,
und ist passenderweise
ein sehr hübsches Molekül,
was es zum Lieblingsmolekül
vieler kuscheliger Chemiker macht.
Was ist euer Lieblingsmolekül?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Wohlgemerkt ist Oxytocin nicht
nur ein Schwangerschaftshormon
oder nur ein Kuschelhormon.
Wie alle Hormone hat es im Körper
verschiedene und komplexe Funktionen.
Aber die Bedeutung
für die Schwangerschaft
steckt ja schon im Namen.
Oxytocin kommt
aus dem Altgriechischen
und heißt so viel
wie "schnelle Geburt".
Weil es die Wehen fördert, also
die Kontraktionen der Gebärmutter.
Außerdem hilft Oxytocin
bei der Milchbildung.
Und beim Stillen kommt es zur
Erhöhung des Oxytocinspiegels,
sowohl bei der Mutter
als auch beim Kind.
Im Moment des Stillens kann das zu
regelrechten Glücksgefühle führen.
Und generell stärkt Oxytocin
die Bindung zwischen Mutter und Kind.
Gegen so eine chemische Bindung
kommt der Papa wohl kaum an, oder?
Erstaunlicherweise schon.
Inzwischen weiß man,
dass auch bei Vätern
das Kuschelhormon erhöht wird.
In dieser Studie aus dem Jahr 2010
besuchten Forscher
80 zusammenlebende Elternpaare,
und bestimmten deren Oxytocin-Level
anhand von Blutproben.
Einmal direkt nach der Geburt
und einmal 6 Monate später.
Zu beiden Zeitpunkten
gab es keinen Unterschied
im Oxytocin-Spiegel
von Müttern und Vätern.
Das deutet darauf hin,
dass Oxytocin
eher mit dem Verhalten zusammenhängt.
Also z.B. ausgeschüttet wird,
wenn man mit dem Kind spielt.
Wenn der Papa das tut,
kann er sich eben auch
seine Ladung Kuschelhormon abholen.
Das war vor 10 Jahren
eine überraschende Erkenntnis.
Das hatte man gar nicht so vermutet.
Was man aber schon
länger wusste ist, dass Väter
einen niedrigeren
Testosteronspiegel haben
als Nichtväter oder Singlemänner.
Man wusste nur nicht,
ob Männer mit 'nem
niedrigen Testosteronspiegel
eher Vater werden
oder ob die Vaterschaft
den Testosteronspiegel senkt.
Diese Studie spricht für Letzteres.
Hier wurde eine Kohorte von über 600
philippinischen Männern untersucht.
Das erste Mal, als die Männer
im Schnitt 26 Jahre alt waren,
das zweite Mal vier Jahre später.
Also im klassischen Zeitraum zum
Heiraten und/oder Kinderkriegen.
Die Ergebnisse waren
sehr interessant.
Männer, die zum ersten Testzeitraum
Single waren
und von vornherein einen
hohen Testosteronspiegel hatten,
hatten eine erhöhte
Wahrscheinlichkeit,
vier Jahre später,
am zweiten Testzeitpunkt,
entweder verheiratet
oder Vater zu sein.
Spannenderweise führte
eine feste Beziehung
zu einem Absinken
des Testosteronspiegels.
Aber besonders tief
waren die Testosteronspiegel
bei frischen Vätern.
Außerdem galt: Je mehr Zeit die Väter
mit ihren Babys verbrachten,
desto tiefer waren auch
ihre Testosteronlevel.
Also: Auch Männer erfahren hormonelle
Veränderungen durch ein Baby.
Auch ohne Schwangerschaft
und Stillen.
Und nicht nur das.
Ändert sich denn auch das Gehirn
durch eine Elternschaft?
In dieser Studie wurden
41 Paare aus Vätern und Müttern
sowie 48 homosexuelle Paare aus
zwei Vätern untersucht.
Man schaute sich alles Mögliche an.
Das Verhalten der Eltern,
Oxytocinspiegel und Hirnscans.
Bei den Oxytocin Messungen
kam das Gleiche raus wie vorhin.
Die Oxytocinlevel waren
bei allen Eltern ähnlich.
Egal ob Vater oder Mutter
und egal, ob schwul oder hetero.
Besonders interessant
waren die Hirnscans.
Dazu legte man die Teilnehmer in
den Scanner und zeigte ihnen Videos
von typischen
Eltern-Kind-Interaktionen.
Dabei waren Videos von den
Teilnehmern selbst mit ihren Kindern,
und auch Videos von anderen Eltern
mit ihren Kindern.
Als Kontrolle gab es noch
ein Video von den Teilnehmern
bei einer alltäglichen Tätigkeit
ohne Kind, z.B. beim Geschirrspülen.
Während die Teilnehmer
die Videos schauten,
zeichnete der Scanner den
Sauerstoffverbrauch im Gehirn auf,
um festzustellen, welche
Hirnregionen besonders aktiv werden,
beim Beobachten
der Eltern-Kind-Interaktion.
Man fand heraus, dass das Beobachten
von Eltern-Kind-Interaktionen
ein bestimmtes Netzwerk
von Hirnregionen aktiviert,
das besonders für
Emotionsverarbeitung zuständig ist.
Dazu gehören z.B.
die Amygdala, die Insula
und er anteriore cinguläre Cortex.
Dieses Netzwerk war
bei allen Eltern aktiviert.
Egal ob schwul oder hetero
und unabhängig davon,
wie viel Zeit sie
mit ihren Kindern verbrachten.
Aber wenn man sich
die Ergebnisse genauer anschaut,
sieht man, dass es
für bestimmte Hirnregionen
doch einen Unterschied gab.
Bei den Heteropaaren
beobachtete man bei den Müttern
eine stärkere Aktivierung
der Amygdala als bei den Vätern.
Die Amygdala ist
die Hornregion, die u.a.
für ein Belohnungsgefühl und
für emotionales Lernen zuständig ist.
Das ist interessant, denn bei
allen untersuchten Heteropaaren
war auch die Mutter diejenige,
die sich vorrangig
um das Kind kümmert.
Also eine klassische
Rollenverteilung.
Doch besonders spannend waren die
Hirnscans der schwulen Väterpaare.
Denn auch hier beobachtete man,
eine verstärkte Aktivierung
der Amygdala
und zwar bei dem Vater, der
mehr Zeit mit dem Kind verbrachte.
Je mehr Zeit ein Elternteil
mit dem Kind verbrachte,
desto stärker war die Verknüpfung
zwischen der Amygdala
und einer weiteren Hirnregion,
die u.a. mit Gesichtserkennung
und Empathie in Verbindung steht.
Diese Studien unterstützen
folgende Hypothese:
Deine Hormone
oder deine Neurologie
geben nicht vor, wie gut du dich
um dein Kind kümmerst, sondern,
wenn du dich
um dein Kind kümmerst,
stellen sich deine Hormone
und dein Gehirn darauf ein.
Aber heißt das, wir unterscheiden
uns da grundlegend von Tieren?
Wir wissen ja, Pinguine z.B.
Die wechseln sich ab
mit Brüten und Futter holen,
die kümmern sich komplett
gleichberechtigt um ihre Babys.
Aber wir sind ja keine Pinguine.
Leider. Die Welt
wäre ein besserer Ort.
Jedenfalls, ich meine Säugetiere.
Bei anderen Säugetieren
scheint es die Regel zu sein,
dass die Mutter
für den Nachwuchs zuständig ist.
Zumindest gewinnt man diesen
Eindruck, wenn man Tierdokus schaut.
Da ist es immer die Mama,
die alleine den Laden schmeißt.
Tatsächlich ist väterliche Fürsorge
unter den Säugetieren
nicht die Regel.
Aber, zu den Ausnahmen,
die die Regel bestätigen,
gehören auch
unsere nächsten Verwandten.
Wir haben Natalia angeskypt,
weil sie verschieden Arten
von Affen beobachtet hat.
Manche dieser Arten leben
in ähnlichen Beziehungen,
wie die meisten Menschen.
In mehr oder weniger
monogamen Beziehungen
zwischen Weibchen und Männchen.
Anthropologen können
sich gut vorstellen,
dass bei den frühen Menschen
es auch komplett
gemeinsames Parenting gab.
Aus anthropologischer Sicht
sind unsere Geschlechterrollen
in der Kindeserziehung
also stark kulturell geprägt.
Und kulturelle Normen ändern sich ja
ständig, nicht nur über Jahrtausende.
Da tut sich einiges. Die Männer
machen das ja auch nicht mehr mit.
Diese Idee, wir arbeiten nur,
die Frauen bleiben zuhause.
Und die Frauen andersrum auch nicht.
Er hält wenig von der Idee,
dass Frauen irgendwie von Natur aus
besser seien in der Kindeserziehung.
Diese Vorstellungen basieren nicht
nur auf veralteten Familienmodellen,
sondern auch auf überholten
wissenschaftlichen Meinungen.
Heute veraltete Positionen
aus der Psychoanalyse z.B.,
sagten immer,
der Vater ist der Dritte im Bunde.
Es gibt 'ne Mutter-Kind-Dyade
da kommt der Vater
als Drittes hinzu.
Der wird das Außen repräsentieren,
holt Objekte rein,
und nach und nach,
wenn das Kind älter wird,
spielt er auch 'ne Rolle.
Das ist aber ganz klar Mythen,
ermittlungspsychologischer Unsinn.
Aber das zu ändern,
auf diesen ganzen Ebenen
und die alten Theorien auszubremsen,
das braucht einfach Zeit.
Diese alten Theorien werden heute
v.a. durch die Praxis wiederlegt.
Wenn wir gucken, ob und wie
sich Väter an Kinder binden,
was Väter mit Kindern machen,
ob sie Kinder bespaßen,
Kinder pflegen können,
ob sie sie erziehen können,
ob sie mit ihnen spielen können,
Vertrauen entwickeln,
ob sie Emotionen entwickeln,
Nähe, Liebe,
dann sehen wir eigentlich,
wenn wir es vergleichbar machen,
den Vätern Raum dafür geben,
sehen wir keine Unterschiede.
Manche Väter sind vielleicht ungeübt,
haben keine Vorbilder,
glauben nicht, dass sie das
können, müssen es erst ausprobieren.
Aber natürlich gibt
es 'ne Vater-Kind-Bindung,
Väter können genauso gut trösten,
auch Väter können
mit kleinen Kindern umgehen,
Väter können sich anpassen,
Väter können wickeln, spielen,
Väter können
in der Ammensprache reden.
Übrigens, Ammensprache ist das hier:
(säuselt) Das ist ja
ein kleines Füßchen.
Und Männer können das auch.
(säuselt) Das ist ja
ein kleines Füßchen.
Nee, das ist ja eigentlich andersrum.
So muss das sein, oder?
Egal.
Aber selbst wenn man sich am liebsten
alles gerecht aufteilen würde,
gibt es noch so ein paar Fallen,
die sich manche Paare
gewissermaßen selbst legen.
Stichwort: Gatekeeping.
Viele Eltern reden
von Gatekeeping,
oft kombiniert mit dem Wort
mütterlich. Mütterliches Gatekeeping.
Gemeint ist, dass hier die Mutter
quasi die Torhüterin ist,
die den Zugang des Vaters
zum Kind reguliert.
Wenn sie das Tor öffnet
und zu ihrem Partner sagt:
Ach, mach du das doch auch.
Du kannst doch mit dem Kind
ebenso gut spielen,
dann tut der Vater das,
wenn die Mutter das Tor zuhält,
und sagt: Ich kann das besser,
oder: das ist Frauensache,
dann tut der Vater sich schwer
und macht es nicht.
Beispiel: Das Kind
möchte nie ins Bett.
Riesen Act das Kind
ins Bett zu bringen.
Die Mama macht es öfter,
hat irgendwann die Tricks raus
und wird zum "Gute-Nacht-Profi".
Der Papa bringt das Kind
nicht so oft ins Bett,
und wenn er es mal versucht,
dauert es direkt dreimal so lange.
So kann es
zu 'nem Teufelskreis kommen:
Der Papa bringt das Kind nie zu Bett,
weil er es nicht so gut kann.
Er kann es aber nicht so gut,
weil er es nie macht.
So können sich ungleiche
Verteilungen einschleichen,
selbst wenn man das als Paar
gar nicht so geplant hat.
Wenn Unterschiede deutlich werden,
wäre es klug, wenn es der macht,
der es nicht so gut kann,
aber das Kind sieht,
ja, das ist ganz normal,
auch Mama oder auch
Papa kann mich ins Bett bringen.
Ähnlich wie beim
Hormonspiegel vorhin,
oder bei der Hirnaktivität,
hängt es auch hier davon ab,
wer wie viel Zeit
mit dem Kind verbringt.
Und je weniger Unterschiede
es da gibt zwischen Mutter und Vater,
desto ausgeglichener
sind die Geschlechterrollen.
Es gibt also
anthropologische, psychologische,
neurologische und
endokrinologische Hinweise darauf,
dass Mütter nicht von Natur aus
bessere Eltern sind als Väter.
Dieses Wissen kann Eltern,
zumindest im Kopf,
mehr Freiheit verschaffen,
um die Erziehung so zu gestalten,
wie man wirklich möchte.
Sei es hauptsächlich Mama
oder hauptsächlich Papa
oder beide möglichst ausgeglichen.
Wissenschaftlich spricht viel dafür,
dass jede Variation
der Aufteilung gut ist,
solange man
ein guter Elternteil sein will.
Aber gesellschaftlich gibt es
für diese Entscheidungsfreiheit
noch einige Hürden.
Vor allem für alle,
die ein weniger klassisches
Familienmodell bevorzugen.
Ich will auf eine dieser Hürden
hier noch eingehen,
weil ich die besonders wichtig finde.
Frauen arbeiten
im Schnitt häufiger
in schlechter bezahlten Berufen
oder Branchen.
Ein typisches Beispiel: männliche
Ärzte, weibliche Krankenpflegerinnen.
Außerdem arbeiten Frauen
öfter in Teilzeit,
und sie unterbrechen
ihre Arbeit länger.
Eben wegen der Kindererziehung.
Und Teilzeit, geringfügige Arbeit
und längere Unterbrechungen
führen nicht nur
zu weniger Arbeitsstunden,
sondern gehen auch mit einem
niedrigeren Stundenlohn einher.
Das sind übrigens die Hauptgründe
für den Gender Pay Gap.
Also den unbereinigten
Gender Pay Gap.
Also die Hauptgründe, warum Frauen
weniger verdienen als Männer.
Hier gibt es auch
gewisse Teufelskreise.
Nehmen wir mal ein
Durchschnittspaar von Heute,
bei dem der Mann mehr verdient
als die Frau.
Dieses Paar entscheidet sich
jetzt für ein Kind
und dafür, dass ein Elternteil
zuhause bei dem Kind bleiben soll.
Oder zumindest viel Zeit
dort verbringen soll.
Wie teilen sie sich jetzt auf?
Rein wirtschaftlich betrachtet,
ist nur eine Sache sinnvoll:
nämlich, dass der Mann,
der mehr verdient,
nicht weniger arbeitet, sondern
die Frau, die ja weniger verdient.
Man kann sich natürlich
frei anders entscheiden, aber
das muss man sich
erstmal leisten können.
Das heißt, der Mann
geht weiter arbeiten,
er kann weiter Berufs- und
Betriebserfahrungen sammeln,
er kann auf eine Gehaltserhöhung
oder Beförderung hinarbeiten,
Die Frau nicht.
Folge: Die Lohnlücke zwischen den
beiden wird in Zukunft nur größer.
Unterschiedliche Ausgangspositionen
reproduzieren Unterschiede.
Das heißt, beim zweiten Kind
bleibt die Frau schon wieder
oder erst recht zuhause.
Und falls man so ein Familienmodell
eigentlich gar nicht möchte,
kann man, aus finanziellen Gründen,
einfach drin steckenbleiben.
Doch Frauen entscheiden sich
nun mal häufiger
für Jobs oder Branchen,
die schlechter bezahlt sind.
Manche finden daher,
man sollte Frauen empowern,
mehr typisch männliche Jobs
zu verfolgen.
Da bin ich einerseits schon dabei,
ich denke aber nicht,
dass das langfristig
und flächendeckend aufgehen würde.
Denn wenn weniger Frauen
typische Frauenberufe machen,
dann muss die jemand anderes machen.
Denn wir sehen jetzt gerade
in der Coronakrise sehr deutlich,
dass viele der typischen Frauenjobs
extrem wichtige,
systemrelevante Jobs sind.
Und wir sehen leider gerade auch,
dass diese systemrelevanten Berufe
bis auf wenige Ausnahmen
schlecht bezahlt sind.
Und das ist nicht in Ordnung.
Egal, ob diese Jobs von Männern
oder Frauen ausgeübt werden,
also, ich finde langfristig
geht diese Ungerechtigkeit
über Genderfragen hinaus.
Da momentan der Frauenanteil
in diesen Berufen recht hoch ist,
gehe ich davon aus,
dass nicht nur der Gender Pay Gap
sich deutlich verkleinern würde,
sondern auch, dass die
Geschlechterrollen in der Erziehung
aufbrechen könnten.
Wenn man nur
systemrelevante Berufe
angemessen bezahlen würde.
Man kann nur hoffen,
dass diese Einsicht
eine der wenigen positiven Folgen
dieser Krise sein könnte.
Wie ist die Rollenverteilung
bei eure Eltern?
Und falls Eltern zuschauen,
wie handhabt ihr das?
Habt ihr auch Gatekeeping Probleme?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr dieses Video
interessant fandet,
empfehle ich euch dieses Video
von Frank und "Die Frage"
Das ist Teil der Serie:
Bin ich bereit für ein Kind?
In der Folge ging es passenderweise
um die Vaterrolle
bei werdenden Eltern.
Verlinke ich hier
und in der Endcard.
Zuletzt noch ein cooles Announcement.
Freunde der Sonne, ich habe erfahren,
dass ich dieses Jahr
den Heinz Oberhummer Award bekomme.
Evtl. seid ihr zu jung,
um Heinz Oberhummer zu kennen,
Ein österreichischer Physiker
und einer der coolsten
und wichtigsten
Wissenschaftskommunikatoren.
Nach seinem Tod wurde der Heinz
Oberhummer Award ins Leben gerufen,
Um sein Wirken und gute
Wissenschaftskommunikation
weiterleben zu lassen.
Ich fühle mich unglaublich dankbar
und geehrt und möchte Danke sagen
an all die großzügigen Menschen, die
diese Entscheidung getroffen haben.
Danke und Grüße nach Wien.
Hier geht's zum Video von "Die Frage"
oder zu einem ausführlichen Video
zum Gender Pay Gap.
Bis in zwei Wochen oder
auf Twitter oder Instagram.
Freunde der Sonne, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2020)